thanks um so i'm going to talk about uh
simple mechanisms for
both an additive and a subadditive buyer
and this is uh based on two works um the
first one joint with uh motion nicole
and brandon and the second one with uh
avion
um so i'm just going to jump right into
the model
since you know we just saw a talk on a
similar one earlier
so there's going to be a one seller and
in this talk just
one additive buyer so not many buyers
and the additive buyer is going to be
interested in these n different items
that the seller has for sale the buyer
is going to be additive for the first
portion of the talk
so that means that the buyer has a value
vi for
item i and his value for a set of items
just sums his value for every item in
that set
the buyer is going to be a risk neutral
and quasi linear which just means that
his utility
for uh receiving a random set and paying
a random price is just his expected
value minus the expected price he pays
and uh similar to what we saw in the
earlier talk the seller is unsure
of the buyer's values exactly but he has
this bayesian prior
that prior is going to be a product
distribution
so the seller is going to have a
one-dimensional distribution
on the buyer's value for each item
and his that joint that product
distribution will be his joint
distribution over
beliefs for the buyers values for all
items
and his goal is going to be to sell the
items in a way that maximizes his
expected revenue
okay so let me go over a couple
different ways that the seller could
choose to sell his items
the first is he could sell the items
separately and so what he would do here
is he would just post the price pi on
item i
and then say to the buyer you can choose
to receive any subset of items you want
if you choose to receive subset s you
have to pay me the sum of the prices for
every item in that set
okay now the pros to using a scheme like
this is that it's
actually very easy for the seller to
optimize over all schemes like this
and it's really trivial for the buyer to
decide what he wants to purchase he says
to visit each item and figure out is my
value larger than the price or not
okay what's also nice is that um
predicting what the buyer will do
doesn't rely on risk neutrality because
there's no randomization
and the buyer doesn't even need to know
his uh values exactly so as long as the
buyer is able to make one
binary comparison then you can
accurately predict uh what he will
purchase
okay and of course the drawback is that
i'm restricting yourself to using a
scheme like this might be sub-optimal
for the seller
and the last thing i'm going to say
before moving on is i'm going to use the
same notation as the
previous talk and i'll use srev to
denote the optimal revenue that the
seller can obtain by using a scheme like
this
another thing that the seller might do
is he can sell all the items together
in one big bundle so what he might do is
he takes all the fruits together and he
says to the buyer
if you choose to pay me price p then you
can get all the
all the fruit if you don't then you get
nothing
okay and again this has the same pros as
selling separately that it's very robust
and it has the same cons and that it
might be sub-optimal for the seller to
restrict himself to using a selling
scheme like this
okay and again just before moving on i'm
going to use this notation b-rev for
bundling revenue to denote the optimal
revenue that the seller can obtain by
using a
scheme of this format
okay now the most general thing that the
seller could choose to do is he could
offer a lottery system
to the buyer okay so here what i mean is
that the seller is going to post the
following possibly
infinitely long menu where in this
example the first option
says to the buyer if you pay me p1 then
you can get the apple
if you pay me p2 you can get the orange
and the bananas
if you pay me p3 then you get the apple
with probability of half and you get the
bananas with probability one
if you pay me p4 you get the orange with
probability of half the apple with
probability three-fourths and the
bananas with probability one-fourth and
you could have an infinitely long list
with different probability vectors
uh for the items and a different price
for each
okay so the upside of using a scheme
like this is that it is in fact
optimal over all possible mechanisms and
protocols that the seller could use
so that's good the downside is that this
is a hard
problem for the seller to optimize so if
he wants to find the optimal lottery
system he would have to write an lp
that's a polynomial in the support of
the buyer's value distribution
it's now not hard for the buyer to
optimize but it is at least
annoying for the buyer to figure out
what he wants to purchase because he
actually has to visit
every option on the menu he has to
compute his expected value and subtract
the price and see what's the largest
and because we're using randomization
being able to predict what the buyer
will purchase actually relies heavily on
this uh
risk neutrality assumption and if we got
that wrong then maybe
the revenue that we predict we'll get
here will be way off
okay and again before moving on the
notation i'm going to use to denote the
revenue of the optimal mechanism
is uh rev
okay so what's the point of going
through this so what we'd like to do
is we'd really like to sell items
separately or together because of these
great robustness properties that they
have but what we really don't want to do
is to sacrifice revenue in the event
that we did get the model right and it
would have been okay to use a lottery
system
okay and uh really quickly i'm not going
to go through all of these examples but
i want to state that there's actually a
lot of
formal barriers to trying and
accomplishing this so
the first one is that we know from this
work of hard and nissan from 2012
that there are examples where selling
separately can only guarantee you a
logarithmic factor of the optimal
revenue
and there are also examples where
selling together can only guarantee you
a linear factor
of the optimal revenue so for both of
them there are examples where they can
be very bad
second is we know from this is just a
sample of works there's a lot more works
actually that provide different examples
that the optimal mechanism
even in very simple instances where say
you have
one buyer two items and each of these
distributions just has support two
then sometimes the optimal mechanism
even in these instances can be
randomized
and there's also a series of papers that
shows that
if these distributions are not
independent
then actually there can be an infinite
gap between the revenue
of the best randomized mechanism and the
revenue of the best deterministic one so
randomization can become essential to
getting revenue
okay and uh the last challenge is
there's this um really weird phenomenon
called non-monotonicity
where the following thing can happen so
maybe you start
with a distribution over a product
distribution over values for two items
and then you go through some advertising
campaign and you
make everyone in the population like
both of your items strictly more than
they did before
and now it can be the case that the
optimal mechanism for this new
distribution
has worse revenue than the distribution
you started with
it's really bizarre that this can happen
but it can
okay so basically i just wanted to
highlight that there are some formal
barriers to this and that's why this has
been kind of a challenging problem for a
while
but there is still some positive results
and what we heard um we heard about this
a little bit earlier was it
lee and yao were able to show that srev
actually is able to guarantee something
it can at least guarantee you a login
approximation to the optimal revenue
and if the all the distributions are iid
then b rev does get you a constant
factor
okay and both of these improved the
bounds that were given in heart and
nissan by a log n factor
and because of the lower bounds on the
previous slide they're asymptotically
tight
okay and you know something we didn't
hear about earlier but there is um
work by cayenne huang that showed if
you're not so concerned about structure
but you just want to be able to find
a good mechanism whatever it is there is
a
ptas if all of the distributions have
the
monotone hazard rate condition
okay so now i want to move into our
result so we did hear this stated
earlier but what we're able to show
is that even though neither selling
separately nor selling together can get
you a constant factor approximation
that for every distribution the better
of selling separately or selling
together does get you a six
approximation
okay and so what i'm going to do for
like the next uh 10 minutes or so is try
and give you
a pretty high level overview of what the
proof of this looks like
and then what i'm going to do at the end
of the talk is uh state
a little bit about the second result i
wanted to talk about
which is that i'm in joint work with
aviad we're able to extend
this result to a setting where the buyer
has combinatorial valuations over the
items
that is subadditive so here he might
have values that are uh
you know depend on exactly which set of
items he gets
okay and but i'm not going to give you a
formal statement now and i'll overview
kind of why these settings are very
different later as well
okay but now i want to get into a proof
overview of the first result
so the first thing we want to look at is
you know okay so what are the examples
where selling separately is a bad idea
okay and so this example is from hard
nissan's paper
and so the bad example is if the buyer's
valuation for every item
is drawn independently from what's
called the equal revenue distribution
so this is a distribution such that the
probability that the buyer's value
exceeds x
is exactly one over x for all x and all
items
okay so it turns out that for this
distribution maybe it should be easy to
see that if you sell
separately you're going to get revenue
exactly n because you're going to get
one per item
no matter what price you set for each
item if you set price x it's going to
sell with probability 1 over x so you
get revenue 1 per item
but it turns out that the sum of values
concentrates pretty tightly
around n log n for these distributions
okay so what does that mean that means
that something you can do
is you can set a price equal to n log n
over two and then the buyer will choose
to purchase this with pretty high
probability and so b
rev is something like n log n okay so
this means that so this is an example
that shows that srev can't guarantee
better than a log n approximation
and the takeaway from this is that s rev
it seems like is bad
whenever the sum of values concentrates
okay but we can note that b rev is at
least good in this case
okay now we can say so when is b rev bad
so here's an example also from hard
nissan
where the value for the items are going
to be like wildly asymmetric
distributions
so here the distribution of values for
the jth item
the buyer's value is going to be 2 to
the j with probability 2 to the minus j
and 0 otherwise okay so now maybe we can
see that if you choose to
sell all the items together in one
bundle there's no way
to get a revenue larger than 2.
this is because for whatever price you
choose to set the probability that the
sum of values exceeds it is at most 2
over x
and i'm not going to go slowly through
the math but this is by taking a union
bound and then observing that this is a
geometric sum
okay but we can still see that if we had
just uh sold each item separately at
price two to the j
we'd go back to getting revenue one per
item which would be n in total
okay so what that means is that uh b rev
can't guarantee you better than
n approximation on every distribution
okay so what we learned here is that b
rev is bad when all items contribute
evenly
but they're on these wildly different
scales
and it turns out that in this case s rev
happens to be good because basically
many of the items are zero with high
probability
and when there are very few items to
deal with srev is okay
okay so the intuition that we gain from
these examples are that
b-rev is good when the sum of values
concentrates
srev seems to be good when most item
values are very small
compared to the rest and so we can ask
does every distribution fall into one of
these two categories where either s5 is
good or brevis good
okay and the answer is not exactly but
we can still use this intuition to guide
the analysis
so formally what we want to do is we
want to use this idea called the
quartal decomposition that was
introduced in lianyl's paper to prove
their results
so what we're going to do is for each
item
we're going to split the support for
that item into the what we'll call the
core
and the tail okay and the tail is what
you would expect we're going to pick
some cutoff
and we're going to say everything that
exceeds this cut off
we'll call the tail and everything
that's below this cutoff we'll call the
core okay and the cutoff we're going to
choose for every item is going to be
exactly
srev
okay so now we can talk about for an
item we can say your value for that item
is in the core
if your value for the item is small and
your value for that item is in detail
if your value for that item is large and
i'm also going to
define some terms so i want to say if i
give you an entire evaluation vector
yes
total s-rev that's right so it's going
to be a very high cutoff
yeah so i also want to say an entire
valuation vector
is in the core if every item is in the
core so if your value for every item is
small
and i'll say that a valuation vector is
in the tail if your value for at least
one item is large and like miles pointed
out this is very large it's larger than
srev for selling all the items together
okay so from here they're basically at a
high level there are three steps
to completing the proof the first step
is we prove something called the
core decomposition lemma and this is
a little bit of an informal statement of
what that lemma says
what it says is that the revenue the
optimal revenue for any distribution
is upper bounded by the total welfare so
the expected sum of values
for that distribution condition on the
values being small
plus the best revenue that you can get
from that distribution
condition on the values being large at
least one of the values being large
or in the tail okay so once we have this
decomposition lemma we just need to show
that srev and b rev can get a constant
factor approximation of each term
separately so bounding the tail
it turns out that the revenue that you
get from the tail is upper bounded by
two times srev
and i'm going to completely skip saying
anything more about the proof of this
but basically what's going on is that we
said that these cutoffs are really
really large
and it turns out that they are so large
that we're unlikely to see more than one
item in the tail
at the same time and so you should see
if there's only one item to deal with
then selling separately is the same
thing as doing the optimal mechanism
and if there's more items in the tail
but not many then it degrades not so
poorly
okay some so that's all i'm going to say
about that but basically because the
cutoffs are large
srev does well on the revenue from the
tail
and the last step is we have to show
that sreverbirev can
obtain a constant factor of the welfare
from the core
okay so here the idea is that maybe the
welfare of the core is less than 4srev
if that happens then great we're in good
shape and srf gets you a constant factor
approximation
if that doesn't happen so what's going
on we said that our cutoffs
were exactly srev so that means we have
a bunch of independent random variables
that are each bounded above by srev and
the expected sum of these random
variables is larger than 4srev
okay and it turns out that this is
actually enough information
to show that the welfare of the core
must concentrate
okay and uh when the welfare of the core
concentrates we can use the same trick
we saw in the example
and just uh set a price equal to like
half of the welfare of the core and then
with good probability the buyer's values
will be above this and it'll choose the
purchase so b rev gets you a constant
factor there
okay so what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to give you
kind of a sample of the small lemmas
that go into the
one lemma that goes into the proof of
step one and one lemma that goes into
the proof
of uh step three so it's not going to be
like a chain of events that will lead to
proofs of these i just want to give you
a sample of what the proofs look like
okay so um one of the key lemmas that
goes into this uh
core decomposition lemma is what's
called the
marginal mechanism lemma and it appeared
in cai and huang's work and also
hardened nissan so it's not our lemma
but i think it's a good sample of the
kind of techniques that go into proving
this
okay and so what this lemma says is that
if you have
two disjoint sets of items
and i have a distribution over values
for one and a distribution over values
for the other
and they're uh both additive then
what's not necessarily true is that the
revenue of selling all the items
together
is upper bounded by the revenue of
selling them separately
but what is true is that the revenue of
selling both together
is upper bounded by the welfare of one
set of items
plus the revenue of the second set of
items
okay and um i think actually i'm
going a little slower than i thought so
maybe i'm going to skip this proof
but i'll talk a little bit while it's on
the slide if you want to try and read it
quickly
so basically what's going on all i want
to say that's important about this proof
is we're going to come up with some
trick
that says if i know exactly how much
value you get
by adding items in s to whatever items
in t
you get then i'm just going to try and
pay you back for these items instead
in a mechanism that used to sell both
items and now i'll only sell the items
in t and i'll just like buy back the
items in s from you
okay so at a really high level that's
what's going on here and
yeah so i'm sorry for going through that
quickly
okay so now for um the analysis of the
core
i think i'll also go through this a
little quickly so
here's just a quick observation that is
going to be helpful for what's coming
next
is that for all items i and for all x
the probability that your value exceeds
x is certainly upper bounded by the
revenue from selling that item by itself
over x so why is this if this was false
then i could offer item i at a price of
x and i would definitely get revenue
that's strictly larger
than the revenue of the i which would
contradict the definition of the revenue
of di
okay and it turns out that this
observation alone is enough for us to
bound the variance
of your value for item i conditioned on
being in the core
okay and it turns out that it's upper
bounded by two times srev times the
revenue of selling just itemized
separately
and so so really all that's going on is
this is a chain of inequalities
and the last step is just going to be
evaluating this integral so maybe
if you want to try and go through that
i'll leave it up there but i won't go
through it
slowly okay so as a corollary of this
lemma
we can show that the variance of your
value your sum of values for all items
condition on being in the core is upper
bounded by two s rev squared
so why is this well d is a product
distribution so variance is additive
across the variance of its components
here's a bound of the variance of its
components so when i sum this overall i
this last sum turns into exactly srev
and that's where the 2srf squared comes
from
okay so once we have this corollary now
we have to look at two cases and this is
like what we said before
one thing that might happen is that the
expected welfare condition on being in
the core
is upper bounded by four s rev if this
happens then clearly the better of s or
f and b rev gets you a four
approximation to this
if this doesn't happen then chebyshev's
inequality says that
uh the sum of values conditioned on
being in the core concentrates
so why is that because the expected sum
of values is larger than 4srev
the standard deviation is less than root
2srev
and so just directly plugging into
chebyshev's inequality says it must
concentrate
so what that means is that you can sell
the grand bundle
at a price equal to two-fifths times the
expected welfare
it will sell with probability at least
five-eighths and this means that
b-rev will get you at least a fourth of
the welfare from the core
okay so just to recap what i said so far
is that there were three steps
the first step was this core
decomposition lemma and what i wanted to
highlight was that the proof used this
marginal mechanism
lemma and what was important was that we
wanted to turn a mechanism that sells
items in
s union t into a mechanism that just
sells items in t
and we did this by basically buying back
from the buyer the items in
s but to do this we needed to know
exactly the buyers values for items in
us
the second thing we did was we uh okay
well i didn't do this but i stated that
we could
up or bound the revenue from the tail
with two srev
and then we uh upper bounded the welfare
of the core with uh four times the
better of s rev and b rev
and again just i want to quickly
highlight that this proof used the fact
that s rev is additive
across items that srev is just equal to
summing over all i the revenue of
selling that item by itself
and we also use the fact that variance
is additive across sums of independent
random variables
okay but this gave the first main
theorem and um
so that's everything i'm going to say
about uh this model
and now i want to move on to
sub-additive buyers
okay and so what i'm going to do is i'm
just going to describe the model
after i describe the model i'll tell you
why
you know this problem is different than
the one we just saw
and then i'm just going to wrap up
okay so here there's still one seller
with n different items for sale there's
one
buyer the buyer has a sub additive
valuation for the items
so that means their value for just the
apple might be this and their value for
the apple and the orange together
might not necessarily be any function of
his value for the apple by itself
and his value for the orange by itself
okay the only thing
i want to assume is that the value for
the union
of two sets is upper bounded by the
value of
each set separately so this is what sub
additive means
okay the seller is again unsure of the
buyer's valuations but has a bayesian
prior
so what is the prior in this case so
it's just a prior
over functions and the only restriction
i want to make on these functions we
need some kind of independence
assumption
the assumption i want to make is that
for any disjoint
sets of items if i look at just the
random variables v
of s1 to v of sk i want these to be
independent random variables
okay so that's the only independence
assumption i want to make about the
distribution
okay and again there's this asterisk
here because actually stating this
correctly is a little bit more technical
but i don't want to go into details
about this in
in spirit this is what the model should
be
okay and again the goal is to sell the
items in a way that maximizes the
seller's expected revenue
okay so i want to give you a couple of
examples because the model is pretty
abstract
of some distributions that do satisfy
our assumptions
so the first is maybe you have a unit
demand buyer so he has a
value for each item that's drawn
independently and his value for a set of
items is just his favorite item in that
set
it could have a k-demand buyer where he
has a value for each item drawn
independently and his value for a set of
items is his favorite k items in that
set
um you could be additive up to more
complex feasibility constraints where
you pick your favorite
feasible set within whatever you're
allocated and some your values for every
item in that set
and maybe the more interesting one is um
you can have
fractionally sub-additive or xos
valuations
where you can have possible values for
each item
that are drawn independently but may be
correlated within an item
and now your value for a set is picking
the
index j that maximizes your sum of
values if i choose index j
across all of the possible values
okay so it still makes sense to sell
separately in this setting
so you can still post the price on each
item and tell the buyer pick whatever
you want
and now one you know something that's
funny here is that now it's actually np
hard just for the buyer to pick his
favorite set
and it's also np hard just to compute
the revenue of a fixed item pricing
okay so these are barriers that somehow
we're going to have to overcome
it still makes sense to uh post a price
on the grand bundle and let the buyer
decide whether he wants to purchase or
not
but again his valuation function is no
longer a sum of independent random
variables so maybe it's not necessarily
going to concentrate
well so somehow we have to overcome this
as well
okay the last thing is that to guarantee
optimality now lottery systems
must offer distributions over all
possible subsets of items
because the buyer's not additive it's
not enough just to consider probability
vectors over the different items so
somehow we also have to accommodate this
okay still we'd like to sell separately
or together because of
the nice robustness properties but we
have to accommodate these new challenges
and um basically there's like no prior
work um
in this problem the what we do know we
have some
impossibility results so we know that if
you relax this independence assumption
then it becomes np hard to maximize
revenue exactly and this was known from
earlier work of dabzinski foo and
kleinberg and we also know that it's np
hard to get
any polynomial approximation so like any
reasonable approximation you can't get
if you don't have this independence
assumption without a signal to stop for
five minutes
okay okay um
okay but still um the punch line i
hinted at earlier is it's still the case
even in this more general model that the
better of selling separately and selling
together
gets you a constant factor approximation
to the optimal revenue
as long as the distribution is
sub-additive with independent items
okay and the um proof actually follows
the same outline as what i showed you
earlier in the talk except there's
each step has some new challenges
basically what i want to do is i'm going
to highlight what these challenges are
and then i'm just going to wrap up with
the conclusion slide
okay so in the first step we said we had
to prove something like a core
decomposition lemma
okay and we saw that one key ingredient
in the proof
was this marginal mechanism lemma that
said we want to turn a mechanism that
sells items in s union t
into one that just sells items in t and
how we're going to do that is we're just
going to pay the buyer
exactly their value for what the items
in s would have been
okay so now the catch is that if the
buyer is sub-additive
then it doesn't make sense to just say
oh i know your value for the items in s
because it depends on exactly what set
of items in t
they got okay so you can't
just go through this kind of argument
directly but what we are able to do is
we prove something that we called an
approximate marginal mechanism lemma
and basically the marginal mechanism
lemma holds
approximately for a sub-additive buyers
okay so again i know that's not a lot of
detail but that's at a high level
one of the techniques that goes on here
okay second is we still have to bound
once we have the core decomposition
lemma we have the bound the revenue of
the tail
and uh again we have this challenge that
it's np hard even to figure out
which items the buyer is purchasing
right so some
very weird structure could be seen in
terms of what items a buyer chooses to
purchase at different prices
and it turns out okay so there is at
least one case
where it's easy to figure out what items
the buyer purchases and that's if he's
only willing to purchase
exactly one item then the buyer will
purchase that item and nothing else
okay and surprisingly it turns out that
only analyzing revenue
from these cases suffices to prove uh
this same bound
okay so it's not clear that this should
be the case but it turns out that it is
the case
okay now the last step is again we have
to bound the uh welfare of the core
using the better of s rev and b rev
okay and just to remind you before um
our earlier proof used the fact that
srev is additive across the items
and we also use the fact that variance
is additive across sums of independent
random variables
okay for sub-additive values just both
of these are no longer true
okay so how we overcome this is again
similarly to how we resolve the issue up
here
only counting revenue from cases where
the buyer wants to purchase
exactly one item overcomes this first
difficulty
and in order to deal with the
concentration it turns out that we can
just invoke a stronger concentration
bound due to work of uh scheckman
and um it turns out that it applies
exactly in the uh model that we need it
to apply to get the result
okay so i know that that's really high
level but uh these three things together
culminate in the main theorem
which is it um for any distribution over
uh sub added evaluations with
independent items
the better of s or evan b rev gets you a
constant factor approximation
so what is this here how do you compute
it
okay so as what we say for srev it turns
out that this
only so i have some pricing scheme and
for this pricing scheme i am only
counting revenue
in instances where the buyer is willing
to purchase exactly one item
so does that make sense
so and then that's my something or not
no
so it's going to be higher it's
basically it's going to be myerson that
sells with
at most some probability so basically
for this srev the prices have to be
really really high so that most of the
time you're only buying one item
and then optimal subject to being at
least so high you can approximately find
those prices
and you can find these prices exactly
okay so just to recap um the first
theorem i showed you is that when the
buyer is additive and the items are
independent that the better of selling
separately and together gets you a six
approximation
second thing i showed you is that if the
buyer is sub-additive but the items are
independent then the better of s or f
and b rev gets you a constant factor
approximation
and both proofs use this uh quartal
decomposition
framework to do it okay so there has
been um
some recent other recent work that um
followed up this first result um by uh
batoni at all
and they showed how to extend um this
first theorem to a model of limited
correlation
so we know that it doesn't hold with
arbitrary correlation because we have
this infinite gap example
but with some model of limited
correlation you can extend this and i
forget exactly what the constant factor
is but you lose another small constant
factor by accommodating correlation um
and second is that um aviyah and i also
were able to show how these results
also imply bounds on this
non-monotonicity phenomenon
okay so basically the idea is that s rev
and b rev are monotone mechanisms
in the sense that if you've restricted
yourself to selling separately
and people like your items more your
revenue can only go up
okay so what that means is that better
product distributions have at least
1 6 of the revenue of distributions that
they stochastically dominate
so in particular this means that if you
go on an advertising campaign
you may hurt your revenue but you're not
going to hurt it more than a factor of
six
okay and uh for you know
and uh for competitive buyers um even
though the
even though srev is no longer a monotone
mechanism
our analysis is and it's basically
because we're only counting revenue from
the case where
most one item sells and um so this
result extends there as well
and um so i'll just put up i think in
this area kind of the main open question
is that um following uh this work
basically there were three
we proposed uh three ways to generalize
it um one
is to non-additive buyers and that was
aviation myself
one was to buyers with limited
correlation and that was botany at all
and then one was to many buyers and
we just saw y'all talk about that
earlier today and
somehow all three of these papers use
different techniques and it doesn't seem
to be trivial to combine
even any two of them but i think that
kind of the central open question here
is ideally to see how just how far
simple mechanisms can go and um that's
all i have thanks
listen
the margin is
so if you are additive between s and t
then it extends so like you can have
crazy valuations within s
and crazy valuations within t but as
long as you're separable across s and t
then it extends exactly and i'm i don't
know i mean norm and sergio are here i
don't know if
they know that it extends beyond that
but
okay so yeah we don't know if it extends
exactly beyond that
uh do you know if you can decompose into
the revenues with the core in the tail
with some factor
um yes so for a single buyer that's
actually the way it was stated in lee
and yao's paper so for a single buyer
you can decompose it into a worse
constant factor
times the revenue of the core plus the
revenue of the tail it turns but
it turns out that the best way we know
how to upper bound the revenue of the
core
is with the welfare of the core so it
made more sense to not lose the constant
factor and just target it directly
instead it's empty hard for the buyer to
optimize
so what's exactly the solution concept
of computationally bounded
buyers do basically assume that they can
do any crazy thing as long as they don't
have any
like opportunity to buy a single item
yes so i would say so even if you get
zero revenue
from buyers who face a tough decision
then this bounce still holds
so basically so as long as you have a
model of buyer where if they have a
trivial decision
they choose to buy the one item that
they like then this bound will hold and
they can do anything crazy
in the other settings okay let's take a
further questions offline i think matt
again
you